but China changed in many ways because
of a decision I made to normalize
diplomatic relations between the United
States and China after 35 years of
estrangement and at the same time they
china announced that on December the
15th 1978 they also announced today
which having complete reform within
China and in China's relationship with
the outside world and so since that date
the first of January in 1979 China has
expanded its freedom within its country
and also has been very aggressive in
their foreign policy so now no matter
where you go in the world or in any
country in Africa or Latin America in
other places you'll find that china is
very deeply involved in the affairs of
that country so China I think is now
destined to be one of the great powers
not only in trade and commerce they've
now exceeded Japan in that respect but
also a great power in international
affairs and I don't believe that China
will ever in my lifetime or maybe my
children's lifetime be equal to the
United States militarily speaking but
they are very careful to avoid any
engagement in war they are basically a
peaceful country which gives them
another advantage over the United States
when we are much more inclined to go to
war for various reasons so China is
going to be a competitor in the future I
hope there'll be a friendly relationship
between the United States and China